hello everyone and don't worry this is
the last video we'll be showing today
from the Magnus Invitational so you can
you know attend to other matters you
know not everything is about chess
it's Hikaru Nakamura versus Magnus
Carlsen and we have reached the face of
Armageddon
so Nakamura with the white pieces has
five minutes on the clock Magnus has
four minutes on the clock and Nakamura
needs to win the game if the game is
drawn or Magnus wins it then the match
goes to Magnus and when I say Nakamura
has five minutes and Carlson has four
that's how it usually works but what
we'll get we'll get to that
so here Nakamura as he was very happy
with both of his games with the white
pieces continues with efore sorry about
that and Magnus goes c5 he was also very
happy with his game where he went for
the Sicilian until that at situation two
moment where Nakamura was able to trick
him but here Magnus is confident that
that will not happen
so tonight of threee six we have a
repetition of game for C captures Knight
captures Knight f6 and Knight to c3
we have d6 and Bishop to e3 and Bishop
to e7 at the savin English Sicilian and
in game four Nakamura went for f4 here
but now he switches the Bishop to e2 he
doesn't want to give Magnus an easy game
and the bishop will nicely support the
old upon pushing that will happen F F
for g4 g5s Nakamura it needs to win this
game to win the match so tonight the c6
and f4 now we have castles by Magnus and
now Knight to b3 avoiding any
unnecessary trades with a6 preparing b5
so of course Nakamura stops it and b6
now preparing to fianchetto the light
square bishop we have castles by
Nakamura and the bishop to b7 by Magnus
with Bishop to f3 I usual move against
Sicilian you want to enforce the e4
square and also challenge white black
slides for Bishop on b7 with Knight to
d7 by Magnus as you are expecting g4g 5
and Nakamura goes for it so g4 and that
there is one game in the database where
Knights the c5 was played
but here we have nice day five instead
and it is as a move 13 that we have a
completely new game
so obviously Magnus is offering a trade
of pieces here even though it will
double up his a pawn but Magnus is very
confident in his knowledge of Sicilian
pawn structure so Nakamura doesn't want
to have anything to do with that so
instead we have g5 Nakamura continues
pushing and now tonight the c-4 goes
after the B to pawn but also after the
bishop on e3 so you defend against both
will bash up the c1 and now II five by
magnets putting pressure on the g5 point
because now if you push f5 you just lose
the pawn here so Bishop to e2 trying to
kick away the night from from c4 and now
comes Luke the see it simply defending
with h4 by Nakamura now the g5 phone is
defended and you cannot allow this pawn
to advance to a5 so Magnus captures on
f4 we have rook captures and now Knight
d5 grabbing more space in the center and
excellent outpost for the knight Knight
to d5 by Nakamura and here Magnus
justice I remind you can have a DD 7
bishop or whatever you want and Knight
to g6 he goes after Nakamura's rook on
f4 we look back to f2 and here
Magnus could go for the h4 pawn but he
first trades in the center with bishop
characters on d5 which is not the most
precise way as a Nakamura will show so
Bishop captures on d5 with a captures on
d5 and only now Knight captures on h4
but now Magnus runs into a double attack
with Queen to d4 with an attack on the
h4 night and also with a double attack
on the c4 Knight
so Magnus has to figure out how to go
about this and he finds the the absolute
best move well the only move that gives
black the advantage bishop characters
and g5 he gives up the night and c4 but
for a lot of contra play so we have
bushel characters in c4 bishop
characters and c1 we have root chakras
on c1 and now Queen to g5 with Czech and
it does connect with the rook and c1
however luckily for for Nakamura the
rook is guarded but there are other
problems here and as you will see later
it was about Adam
this moment that Nakamura received a
message from the arbiter a regarding the
game while the game was being played
that he should abort the game and that
they should redo the game because it
wasn't Nakamura who had a minute extra
on the time he even had less time on the
clock it was some sort of a blunder they
had they made in just twenty four which
you gave Carlsen even more time on
Armageddon which really makes no sense I
haven't I haven't seen the the live
coverage of the Armageddon so if anyone
knows like specifically everything what
happened to do share in the in the
comment section below I will pin it so
everyone else can see but it was it was
something weird so Nakamura has to
decide between king h1 and king to f1
and it's not an easy decision Nakamura
went for King to f1 however King to h1
is the way to go even though it would be
impossible to realize why with so little
time on the clock because after Queen h5
you have Bishop to e2 now challenging
the Queen but you have Knight f3 check
which connects with the Queen and then
after king g2 you can trade here Knight
captures Bishop captures on h5 Knight
captures and b3 you cannot recapture
because of captures and now you have to
move the rook now your knight is under
attack so once the Knight moves now you
capture on f7 and the game continues and
Nakamura said that it wouldn't have made
a difference it would have made a
difference regarding whether how the
game continues but Nakamura still needs
to win this and this is a far from from
winning for for white after King h8 it's
still black who's who's better as he is
up upon but ok Nakamura went king to f1
after that awkward message from the
arbiter and now this runs into a bit of
a problem after Knight to f5 from
Carlsen and now there is not much white
can do because if you move the Queen
wherever you move the Queen doesn't
really matter 93 check connects with the
bishop on c4 so after the King moves
you're just going to trade and pick up
the bishop you're gonna yup two pawns in
a much better position
also this pawn is hanging so it would be
just a a winning endgame for black
so instead Nakamura decided to give up
the rook we have Queen captures on f5
King g2 and our Magnus delivers check
King Queen g5 check
King of three queen a5 check we have
King to g2 and now Magnus is happy
repeating although he should go for
something like this if this was a real
game but he only needs a draw to win the
match so he's a very very happy with
Queen g5 check King to f3 and here
Magnus repeats Queen a5 check and now
Hikaru Kaneda you know walk the plank or
settle for a draw and lose the match so
he decides to go with the plank
King he - but now rook fe8 comes with
check with King to d2 and now Magnus
just delivers rook to e4 and it was in
this position that he called Nakamura
resigned the game and with it he lost
the match now there's not much you can
do here your queen is under attack and
when the Queen moves of course you will
lose the bishop so whatever you do just
captures in the whites position is
completely hopeless
so yeah and also yeah I prepared a here
we go this is a Nakamura's tweet that he
wrote after the game so he says a fun
match a very unsatisfactory ending with
the arbiter writing a message to me in
the middle of the game - abort while I'm
thinking about linking if one or King h1
not that it changes the outcome but
still it might have changed the outcome
of the game although unlikely of the
match as Nakamura needed a win with the
white pieces but you know it does rattle
you and everyone thought that Nakamura
would request a replay or that they
would have to play another game as it
wasn't fair that he received the less
time but he as I understand he requested
no such thing and in the end Magnus wins
the match so like I said if anybody
knows exactly what happened and what
what you know sorcery was at work here
do write in the comments section I will
pin it and you know so everyone else can
see as well but yeah that's that's the
first match we're showing
cos inverse Nakamura Carlsen wins it and
we are continuing with ding vs. Alireza
before we before the start of tomorrow's
games so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Constantinus mafra mattis for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
both of them will be from the Magnus
invitational and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of more games
the Magnus Invitational so thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day